let's say you need to divide one two  three four by five there's a neat trick  to divide any number by five  you need to multiply the number by two  and then divide by ten  so to divide one two three four by five  we multiply by two to get two four six  eight then you divide by ten by moving  the decimal point over by one spot to  get  246.8 and that's the answer  but why does this trick work  let's say you want to divide a number n  by five  5 is equal to 10 over 2 so this is  equivalent to n divided by 10 over 2.  now inverting and multiplying gives n  multiplied by 2 over 10.  rearranging gives 2N multiplied by 1  over 10 which is exactly equal to 2N  divided by 10 and that's why the trick  works